[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
está conmigo en el estudio elvis mendes
uricho louis bienvenido nuevamente al
estudio para hablar de el foro económico
mundial que se lleva a cabo en davos
suiza perspectiva no para el crecimiento
de la economía global un análisis al día
de hoy sobre lo que es este proceso de
recuperación tras la pandemia pero las
conclusiones son medianamente
alentadoras si podemos decirlo así de
acuerdo con lo anunciado por la
consejera del fondo monetario
internacional- guita que opinas de ya
que hay diversos factores que han
limitado la respuesta que venía teniendo
dicho crecimiento obviamente uno de
estos factores tiene que ver con la
guerra en ucrania que ha incrementado
problemas existentes como la información
que ya venía siendo un factor a tomar en
cuenta debido a la crisis en la cadena
de suministro todo ello derivado de la
pandemia de kobe 19 precisamente el
proceso de recuperación de los bloqueos
y la caída económica por el brote ha
sido más lentos hay que recordar que
días atrás kristalina georgieva señalaba
en este mismo escenario que la recesión
global no es segura pero es algo que no
se puede descartar actualmente a lo
propio quita opina primera subdirectora
gerente del organismo ha manifestado que
si bien se están tomando correctivos
como lo es el aumento en la tasa de
interés es estos se han visto
obstaculizados y también podrían generar
diversos problemas a futuro escuchemos
la guerra en ucrania provocó retroceso
en la recuperación mundial tuvimos una
fuerte rebaja en la tasa de crecimiento
global y el mundo continúa enfrentando
vientos en contra porque tenemos una
crisis del costo de vida los precios de
los productos básicos incluidos el
combustible y los alimentos están
subiendo en todo el mundo
world y louis quiero preguntar sobre
algún panorama digamos favorable para la
recuperación paisaje en los próximos
años no pero si dio un resultado
alentador que opinan durante su
intervención ya que es probable que todo
regrese a la normalidad a los niveles
que tenían antes de la pandemia sobre
todo las economías avanzadas para el año
2024 escuchemos
projections las economías avanzadas
según nuestras estimaciones básicamente
volverán a donde habrían estado en
ausencia de la pandemia en 2024 pero las
economías emergentes y en desarrollo
estaría en un 5% por debajo de donde
habrían estado sin la pandemia lo
webwill bing en días eso depende a mike
y bien así entonces está la situación en
torno a la economía global y sobre todo
en este ámbito de la recuperación que se
ha visto impactado por la crisis en
ucrania así es y vamos precisamente a
hablar algo relacionado con esta guerra
en ucrania y rusia porque el gobierno de
vladímir putin no va a poder pagar sus
obligaciones en dólares luego de una
nueva sanción de eeuu así es raúl fuego
anunció el departamento del tesoro el
día de ayer que anunció que no iba a
renovar la licencia que le permitía a
algunos plan bancos de eeuu recibir el
dinero del gobierno de vladímir putin
para hacer frente a sus obligaciones a
través de estas instituciones
financieras la medida entró en vigor
este 25 de mayo e impide y rusia le
pague a inversionistas internacionales
ya que este marzo luego el
establecimiento a las primeras sanciones
del departamento del tesoro había
otorgado una licencia a los bancos para
procesar cualquier pago ruso en dólares
días atrás durante el encuentro que
sostuvo la secretaria del tesoro ya
entienden en alemania como parte de las
reuniones de los ministros de finanzas
del g7 se había adelantado que podría
abrirse una ventana para que los
investigadores pudiesen tomar acción
ante esta medida sin embargo los bancos
estadounidenses utilizados por el
kremlin que verían la negativa en la
licencia le restaría en capacidad de
rusia para pagar a los inversionistas
todos los compromisos adquiridos y por
ello es probable que pueda esta nación
caer en un incumplimiento de pagos
ahora louis seguimos en rusia porque su
banco central llamó a una reunión
extraordinaria
así es una reunión extraordinaria luego
de analizar lo que son las perspectivas
de inflación en ese país es de acuerdo
con la agencia de noticias que
establecida en rusia- interfax ésta
detalla que no hay datos del por qué fue
cambiada la fecha y la hora de la
reunión que está prevista para mañana
jueves de esta junta directiva que va a
discutir la tasa clave todo ello se
desprende tras analizar una disminución
en cuanto a las expectativas
inflacionarias de rusia ya que a
principios de esta semana de acuerdo con
la nota alexis abot kings el
vicepresidente del banco central ruso
había manifestado que existe espacio
para un recorte en las tasas de interés
recordemos que rusia desde el pasado mes
de abril venía aumentando las tasas
noticias de nuestra región en materia
económica vamos hasta brasil porque
podría convertirse en un importante
aliado agrícola de china louis no
refleja un informe del medio global time
muy cercano al gobierno chino que está
como para impulsar la cooperación
económica en materia agrícola a través
de exportaciones de maíz harina de soya
y maní esto forma parte del plan de
china para la importación de cereales
que cubran las necesidades de un
procesamiento agrícola más profundo de
acuerdo con un comunicado del ministerio
de comercio chino citado por el global
times ya fue firmado un acuerdo entre el
ministerio de agricultura de brasil y la
administración general de aduanas hay
que recordar que en 2021 china importó
28.3 millones de toneladas de maíz un 15
como 2% más que en el año 2020 y ahora
vamos al vecino argentina porque sigue
avanzando en su plan para ordenar la
deuda externa estoy de acuerdo con el
medio de esa nación ámbito financiero
que establece que el ministro de
economía martín guzmán podría comenzar a
negociar en junio la deuda que la nación
tiene con el club de parís para ello
debe esperar el informe que presentará
la misión del fondo monetario
internacional
respecto al primer trimestre que tiene
que ver con los acuerdos alcanzados
el pago de la deuda con el fondo
monetario internacional esto serviría
como un aval para el país sudamericano
de cara a esta negociación que ya cuenta
de antemano con el respaldo de alemania
y francia- recordemos que son más de dos
mil millones de dólares lo que argentina
le debe al club de parís indicadores
económicos hay que señalar que en este
caso los mercados asiáticos cerraron de
manera mixta todo ello presionado por
las expectativas que existe en torno a
los precios del petróleo y también por
lo que tiene que ver con la situación en
la guerra en ucrania en auge en europa
también hay números mixtos a lo largo de
la jornada que continúa desarrollándose
cifra el día para finalizar este último
viene que ver en este caso con los 1.500
millones de dólares que el banco
africano de desarrollo pondrá a
disposición de los agricultores dentro
del programa de producción de alimentos
de urgencia un programa que estaría
siendo beneficiando o beneficiando en
este caso a unos 20 millones de
agricultores en este territorio gracias
y como siempre por toda la información
económica nos vemos mañana con más
economía en directo américa nos vamos
directo hasta parís